P TV  when you fall like is that your mommy  that I can't you put you on your feet  you on your feet and if your  what you need  what  [Music]  [Music]  I will do it  [Music]  and long after you go you're my back  [Music]  drugs with my legs down  I've always  I could draw baby don't stop beating  [Music]  [Music]  like a drum baby don't stop beating like  a drum baby don't stop lead and  like a drum baby don't stop beating like  a drum my heart never stops beating for  you long after you're gone gone gone I  love you long after you  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  ladies and gentlemen the newest the icon  the man is hanging from that ceiling in  a way that he will never be forgotten  Duane it's all yours man  [Applause]